le président du parti républicain
dialoguer avec lui vous avez la parole
dans une dizaine de minutes au standard
0 1 45 24 7 milles sur les réseaux
sociaux et l'application mobile d'inter
christian jacob bonjour bonjour et merci
d'être à notre micro emmanuel macron est
aujourd'hui à la mer de glace pour
illustrer les dégâts du réchauffement
climatique et promouvoir le virage
écologiste de la deuxième partie de son
quinquennat vous à droite vous défendez
une certaine idée de la famille une
certaine idée de l'ordre une certaine
idée de la nation votre famille
politique c'est celle des conservateurs
et sané dans ma bouche ni une insulte ni
une caricature alors pourquoi l'écologie
est-elle un angle mort dans ce
conservatisme car après tout il s'agit
simplement de conserver une terre
vivable et de conserver une nature
vivante
pourquoi donc avez vous tendre
maladroite à formuler un discours une
pensée sur l'écologie tu pas d'accord
avec vous je suis pas d'accord parce que
je pense que nous avons et un message
est justement un socle d'idées apporter
d'abord en prenant je reprends la
chronique d'anthony bellanger elle est
très intéressante parce qu'on voit bien
que l'écologie faut être sur une
approche globale on peut pas le
dissocier de la démographie
lorsque l'on parle démographie on parle
logements ont par l'alimentation
on parle au ski ce qu'il a évoqué à
l'instant et donc aujourd'hui la lutte
nécessaire contre le réchauffement
climatique il faut bien prendre en
compte ces notions de démographie on a
besoin il y à une augmentation de la
demande alimentaire mondiale
il faut être capable d'y répondre la
france doit être capable et l'union
européenne d'y répondre
il faut le faire en respectant
l'environnement donc on ne peut pas
opposer écologie et production et
productivisme d'une certaine d'une
certaine manière et c'est ça le discours
de droite
c'est un discours qui allie à la fois
l'écologie et l'économie
on ne peut pas dissocier l'un de l'autre
c'est tout le tout la logique mois que
j'ai toujours développé que nous
développons celle autour du
développement durable
voyez des trois piliers sur une
entreprise une entreprise quelle qu'elle
soit et doit d'abord avoir une
rentabilité économique si elle n'a pas
de rentabilité économique et ne tient
pas dans la durée
ensuite elle doit être fact
de progrès social c'est à dire qu'on met
en remet l'homme au sens du dispositif
les fruits d'une entreprise doit
bénéficier à ceux qui on travaille
et ensuite elle doit être respectueuse
de l'environnement parce que c'est ça
qui assure sa durabilité et le discours
de droite c'est au tour de sa qui se
construit se construit pas sur des
dogmes
oui mais on voit bien que ce discours là
pour l'instant n'est pas suffisant pour
mettre fin au réchauffement climatique
qu'il faut aller plus loin et c'est là
où on se demande jusqu'où vous êtes
capable d'aller plus loin parce que là
vous nous vous nous faites un panorama
sur les idées mais concrètement vous
faites quoi par exemple par exemple la
vallée de chamonix puisque le président
a public est là bas la veille de
chamonix qui est particulièrement
polluée est ce que vous êtes une pour
une taxe poids lourds sur la vallée de
chamonix par exemple pour les camions
qui passent dans la veille cheb mami est
ce que vous êtes pour ou contre ça moi
je suis favorable et nous l'avons dit à
une taxe carbone qu'ils soient aux
frontières de l'union européenne serre
que je ne pense pas que la france seule
bien évidemment qu'il y a des 10 il a
promis la france seule ne peut pas
lutter nous sommes et ça n'est pas rien
pour un pour cent dans l'est dans les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre les
émissions mondiales
donc ça veut pas dire qu'on n'a pas s'en
occuper bien évidemment mais faut être
dans une approche globale
lorsqu'on défend des lorsqu'on défend
l'idée d'une taxe carbone aux frontières
de l'union européenne
c'est ça c'est effectivement une
diminution des émissions de gaz à effet
serre ges bien qu'encore il faut se
mettre d'accord à 27
et oui oui mais quand on aime ça nous
donc tant qu'on n'est pas d'accord à 27
ça nous exempte de nos obligations
on n'aurait pas chez nous non non non
c'est parce que j'étais justement dit
que c'est pas parce que c'était un pur
sang que ça devait pas nous nous
concerner et donc on doit aussi avancé
et c'est l'initiative qu'on attendait du
président de la république qui n'a pas
pris sur le plan européen
ensuite on doit aussi avoir être moins
dépendant des énergies fossiles
d'où le développement je parlais
d'agriculture à l'instant de
l'alimentation et bien c'est le
développement des biocarburants c'est à
dire des carburants qui ne sont pas
polluants et qui sont beaucoup beaucoup
moins polluant on a aujourd'hui un mot
sur le sur les biocarburants
vous développez ces biocarburants ils ne
sont pas émetteurs beaucoup moins
émetteurs de gaz à effet de serre et est
quasiment totalement décarbonés et en
même temps quand vous faites ça eh bien
vous produisez des produits de
substitution
gestion des céréales c'est à dire qu'ils
vont remplacer le soja qui vont éviter
qu'on importe du soja du brésil aux
états unis qui traverse l'atlantique
avec toutes les productions de carbone
qui peut y avoir donc on gagne sur les
deux fronts donc il faut pas s'attaquer
uniquement la logique de taxation mais
trouver des énergies de substitution
mais c'est là que désicion voler en plus
pour vous ne voulez plus investir dans
l'éolien les énergies renouvelables
parce que je pense qu'aujourd'hui les 70
ou 80 millions d'euros qui sont mis dans
les éoliennes qui dénaturent nos
paysages si on les mettait sur
l'isolation des logements
si on la mettait sur le fait de
renouveler d'avoir des chauffages qui
soit beaucoup plus performant
je pense que c'est beaucoup plus
intelligent d'abord ça diminuerait les
coûts de consommation d'énergie pour les
les gens qui sont dans ces logements et
ce serait beaucoup plus efficace que de
saccager nos paysages avec des éoliennes
christian jacob emmanuel macron a
déclaré que le nucléaire était une
chance historique pour la france car
c'est je le cite la production non
intermittente la plus d'écart abonnés au
monde donc dans le droit fil de ce que
vous venez de dire à léa salamé vous
êtes d'accord j'imagine avec sa position
sur le nucléaire sur le nucléaire où je
suis d'accord
en sachant que le nucléaire n'est pas
une fin en soi et que l'énergie des
halles c'est l'énergie renouvelable et
donc il faut continuer à travailler sur
la recherche sur la biomasse sur
différentes techniques sur la
méthanisation sur d'autres possibilités
mais aujourd'hui c'est l'énergie la plus
décarbonés et la moins chère qui existe
la coalition entre les conservateurs les
écologistes autrichiens est ce que ça
vous fait réfléchir vous pourriez le
faire ce serait envisageable en france
une alliance entre vous et les écolos de
yannick jadot par exemple c'est la pure
science fiction
aujourd'hui je vois pas sur quelle base
c'est ça peut faire parce que on a un
mouvement vert en france qui est très
politisée qui était d'abord un mouvement
venus parfois de l'extrême gauche ou de
l'un ou de la gauche et donc il ya quand
même une logique d'opposition sur le
plan économique assez frontal
ceci étant après les îles est pas
interdit aux verts d'évoluer
et l orne l'autre axe des deux
prochaines années du quinquennat c'est
la sécurité les questions régaliennes
comme on dit emmanuel macron vaudois va
s'exprimer sur l'influencé étrangère
dans la formation des imams dans le
financement des lieux de culte pardon
qu'attendez vous concrètement de lui
d'abord c'est le discours qui nous a
tenus en janvier 2018 en juin 2010 8 en
janvier 2019
donc là maintenant il nous l'annoncent
pour les sons les semaines les semaines
à venir
derrière cela rien ne change moi je
pense que on est face à une vraie une
vraie inquiétude d'une ampleur il ya des
attaques sur la laïcité quand on les a
jamais je sais pas si vous avez vu c'est
cette enquête de jérôme fourquet pour
pour l'ifop je crois où il dit que 27%
des musulmans en france favorable à ce
que les lois de la charia dépasse les
lois de saint paul aux lois de la
république
c'est inquiétant le président de la
république ne réagit pas sur ces sujets
lorsqu'il dit que le port du voile dans
l'espace public ça n'est pas son
problème
imaginons que jacques chirac en 2004 et
raisonner de la même façon en disant ça
n'est pas mon problème on en saurait où
aujourd'hui s'il n'y avait pas eu cette
loi d'interdiction sur le port des
signes religieux à l'école
si nicolas sarkozy en 2010 sur la
proposition de jean françois copé sur
l'interdiction de la burqa avait réagi
comme emmanuel macron en disant ça n'est
pas mon problème on en serait ou
aujourd'hui le président nous annoncent
tous les trois mois un grand discours
sur la laïcité
bon d'abord on est pressé de l'entendre
et puis au delà de ça ça n'est pas des
phrases qu'on attend du président de la
république mais ce sont des décisions il
a promis des décisions notamment sur sa
faim notamment sur le fonctionnement
l'islam de france
il parle de séparatisme par exemple
est-ce que c'est un terme qui qui vous
semblent justes de séparatisme dans
certains territoires
j'ai envie de que nous ayons des
des décisions qui soit qu'ils soient
très concrète aujourd'hui arrêts jeudi
tous les trois mois il nous annonce
qu'il va faire un discours sur la
laïcité que con parce qu'on passe aux
actes sur le sur le fichier sur les
personnes qui sont fichés pour
radicalisation c'est un fichier je crois
où il ya à peu près vingt mille
personnes dessus on à 3500 étrangers qui
sont dessus pourquoi ces 3500 étrangers
sont toujours présents en france sur les
condamnations très fermes tous ceux qui
consultent régulièrement les sites qui
appellent à la violence et à la haine
qu'est ce qui a été fait sur ce sujet
sur la fermeture des mosquées sur le
fait que les imams devraient de mon
point de vue obligatoirement prêcher en
français donc on a rien là dessus rien
n'a été fait c'est ça le reproche que
nous faisons au président la république
en dix ans a dit quand je vous dis au
moins d'octobre dernier le dit ça n'est
pas mon problème mais enfin qu'est ce
que je suis fière aux députés que ce ça
va être le grand axe soit une deux sur
la corde il nous le dit depuis trois ans
et le stade est que ce soit vrai mais
nos clés pour le moment y'a rien
d'accord mais bien réaffirmer le droit
au blasphème à la critique de la
religion
il a soutenu clairement là la jeune mis
là vous êtes vous mis là comme on dit
d'ailleurs christian jacob
j'ai horreur de ce type d'expression en
revanche je suis pour la liberté de
culte en france mais pour la liberté de
critiquer tous les cultes et ce qui
s'est passé à l'égard de cette jeune
fille est totalement disproportionnée
elle des critiques dures sur une
religion enfin est-ce que ça peut
justifier quelques moments que ce soit d
appel au viol les appels à l'assassinât
des appels à la haine face la folie ce
qui c est ce que le gouvernement avait
un traité puisque aujourd'hui à l'héro
scolarisés moins qu'on puisse dire c'est
que la ministre la justice a très mal
réagi après tu es heureux qu elle se
reprenne après ce qu'elle avait dit une
question sur le point qui cite une
enquête qui sort aujourd'hui sur les
élus ses élus qui passent des alliances
avec des islamistes notamment banlieue
avec un gros plan sur jean christophe
lagarde député la seine saint denis
et l'édile qui l'aurait fait avec les
islamistes pour asseoir son pouvoir dans
des villes
comme drancy ou comme bobigny est ce que
vous avez entendu parler de cette
enquête
est ce qu'il faut est-ce qu'il faut
sanctionner plus durement les élus
quelle est votre position
écoutez si c'est le cas c'est non
seulement c'est inacceptable mais c'est
extrêmement dangereux
bon j'ai entendu les les les annonces
sur cette enquête objectivement je le
fais pas je ne les ai pas lues et
demandent toujours être à être vérifiée
parce que les tellement facile aussi de
porter des accusations gratuites
ceci étant c'est un point sur lequel on
ne peut pas transiger
on ne peut pas transiger avec d'aider
des gens qui se nourrissent de la haine
qui la revendique i apèl qui appellent à
la haine c'est ce que je disais à
l'instant cirque aujourd'hui l'état et
le président de la république doit se
saisir de ce sujet et je lui
reprocherais directement de ne pas
l'avoir fait et on l'a au mois de
l'automne dernier je l'appelais a
constitué une commission sur la base la
commission stasi ce qu'avait fait le
président chirac à l'époque rien n'était
fait il admis trois mois ce que son
directeur de cabinet me dise qu'il avait
bien reçu la lettre on l'emmène pas
reporter on est heureux on est
heureusement mois après le courrier
arrive j'ai refait une lettre ouverte la
semaine dernière aucune réponse
le président reste mais on a le
sentiment qu'il est tétanisée sur ce
sujet alors quand il est dans les cordes
il dit je vais faire des annonces
bon avant d'en venir aux retraites un
mot sur les chiffres du chômage qui sont
tombés ce matin en nette baisse
8,1 pour cent 7,9 si on ne compte que la
métropole c'est le taux le plus bas en
12 ans christian jacob bonne nouvelle
est que dites vous de la politique
économique du gouvernement qui a rendu
possibles ces chiffres d'abord un c'est
une très bonne nouvelle
2 malheureusement ces chiffres la baisse
est moitié moins importante qu'elle
l'est dans tous les pays de la zone euro
pourquoi le chômage baisse deux fois
moins vite en france que dans les autres
pays de la zone euro parce que nous
n'avons pas fait dans la forme de
structure parce que les dépenses
publiques continuent à exploser
parce que la dette continue à augmenter
de manière abyssal parce que les
déficits publics continue à se dégrader
c'est ça n'arrête pas de réformes de
structure dont les résultats on s'en
félicite et c'est heureux mais deux ils
sont moitié moins important que dans les
autres pays de la zone euro oui mais
sauf que c'est une tendance est en train
de se vérifier qu'on n'a jamais été
aussi bas depuis 11 ans non mais je vous
dis c'est une bonne nouvelle mais les
autres tous les autres pays de la zone
euro le chômage baisse deux fois plus
vite qu'en france venons en donc aux
retraites comme prévu c'est le texte du
gouvernement sans les amendements de
l'opposition qui sera présenté et
discuté en séance à l'assemblée
nationale la commission spéciale n'a pas
pu examiner les vingt mille amendements
déposés de qui est ce la faute
christian jacob de la france insoumise
et de sa grève du zèle
c'est pas la première fois que quand on
est confronté à ce genre de chose les
communistes l'avait l'avait déjà fait il
ya quelques il ya quelques années nous
nous avons nous sommes pas rentrer dans
ce jeu nous avons présenté un
contre-projet qui est structuré avec un
financement pour les retraites
moi ce que je mesure est ce qui fait
réagir aujourd'hui le parlement et
toutes les oppositions
c'est ce mépris du parlement ne
président de la république et ce
gouvernement qui ont méprisé les corps
intermédiaires qui ont méprisé les les
élus locaux qui ont méprisé les français
avec des phrases assassines du président
de la république lorsqu'il parle de ceux
qui ne sont rien et c'est là c'est la
même chose pour le parlement ont dit aux
députés voter le texte voté cette
réforme
et puis surtout vous l'a voté vite parce
qu'on a autre chose à faire que de
perdre du temps avec vous et puis le
financement sont n'occupera plus tard
parce que c'est pas de votre niveau
on verra ça dans deux mois
c'est irresponsable jamais ne démocratie
n'est traité de cette manière
dans quel autre pays occidental un
budget qui représente 15% du produit
intérieur brut
on dit au parlement écoutez vous êtes
gentil mais vous occupez pas de ça vous
fait ce qu'on vous dit et surtout vous
le faites vite il sera privé quoi le
vous demandez quoi hier bernard
cazeneuve à votre place disait il faut
suspendre la réforme il faut enlever
l'âge pivot il faut se remettre autour
de la table il faut en tout cas en
premier lieu suspendre les choses vous
vous demandez quoi
ab nous on demande on avait demandé
l'arrêt de cette réforme est reposé une
vraie réforme sur la table avec un
budget en face nous nous avons un compte
et retirer le kwh a retiré le texte
aujourd'hui y'a plus rien ce texte
personne n'y comprend rien il n'y a même
pas le financement et mais jamais dans
un parlement digne de ce nom
on présente un projet comme celui-là ce
sens le financement hier les députés
vont voter sans savoir comment ce sera
financée et la réalité des choses vous
avez commencé à se finir ça va se finir
par une baisse des pensions et par une
augmentation des cotisations et par une
explosion de la fiscalité
parce que le gouvernement n'aura pas le
courage de prendre la mesure d'âge qui
s'imposent on va passer au standard pour
ouvrir le dialogue avec les auditeurs de
france inter je salue lilou qui nous
appellent de paris bonjour et bienvenue
bonjour bonjour à tous
bonjour monsieur jacob bonjour alors je
suis en classe 2 premiers actuellement
je suis d exploser sur le changement
climatique je plaisante de la tat enders
en anglais j'ai quitté éco-délégués je
me demandais ce que c'est pas un peu
facile de concentrer votre débat sur le
changement climatique autour de la
figure de gratte attentats est de lutter
de retourner à l'école
alors que vous proposez pour le
municipal de cesser d'investir dans les
énergies renouvelables est ce que c'est
pas totalement déconnecté en 2020 après
une année exceptionnellement chaudes de
proposer dont continue d'isoler les
maisons et de ne pas aller un peu plus
loin et je trouve qu'il n'ya pas un
problème générationnel est à dire que
par rapport à un autre génération qui
manifestent pour le climat c'est pas une
coupure encore plus fort et un clivage
entre votre femme politique qui se
coupent totalement des préoccupations
actuelles
vous avez quel âge d'où lé 16 ans
oui c'est
on va prendre notre retraite parce que
là c'est pas que l'avenir est en marche
c'est qu'il est déjà là incroyable
question bravo à lille où elle est très
structuré donc je la livre en vente hier
à christian jacob
écoutez nous ce que ce géant d d'évoquer
il ya quelques instants
je suis favorable à une approche globale
la nécessité de lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique et je ne pose
pas bon mon raisonnement pour un conte
greta groenberg ce n'est pas notre le
plein essor et parce que cette
génération qui demande beaucoup plus
qu'ils demandent de changer de modèle
économique qui ne croient pas à la
croissance verte qui va aller plus loin
c'est ça qu'elle représente l'auditrice
mais bien sûr mais mais écoutez j'ai pas
le sentiment d'être totalement
déconnecté bon peut-être que c'est le
cas mais en tout cas c'est pas le
sentiment que chez moi je considère
encore une fois qu'il faut répondre à
l'explosion démographique que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure
donc ça veut dire qu'il ne peut pas
opposer la production et la productivité
alain à l'environnement qu'on peut lier
qu'on peut lier les deux
et quand je disais plus tôt que de
saccager nos paysages avec avec des
éoliennes il vaut mieux avoir une
meilleure isolation du logement il vaut
mieux être capable de répondre à la
demande alimentaire
donc c'est une approche globale moi je
suis vraiment à disposition et à
disposition pour aller dans le lycée de
lilou et débattre avec ses camarades de
classe sans aucune difficulté et avec
bonheur
il est possible que vous en débatte y
est avec l as microbus puis ses talents
oratoires mai
ur à pauline sur l'application de france
inter vous demande la chose suivante
christian jacob
les éoliennes dénature nos paysages mais
pas les centrales nucléaires il y en a
un peu moins
oui certes on vous voyez le témoin oui
je voi idem il y en a un peu moins
et effectivement je considère moi que
les les éoliennes aujourd'hui la
performance économique le moins qu'on
puisse dire n'a pas été démontrée et je
trouve pas ça très joli pas plus que des
pylônes électriques les pylônes
électriques en lézard bon on essaie de
faire en sorte de pouvoir enfouir les
lignes mais enfouir les éoliennes c'est
un peu plus compliqué laurent vous pose
la question suivante monsieur jacob
sait-il que les agrocarburants entre en
concurrence avec les cultures vivrières
voir les problèmes de maïs aux états
unis et sont incompatibles avec
l'alimentation de la population
croissante de la planète nord il a tort
ce monsieur c'était vrai sur les
premières générations ça ne l'est plus
aujourd'hui
sur les deuxième génération de
biocarburants qui justement n'utilise
pas la partie alimentaire quand vous
craquez une céréale sur la deuxième
génération de biocarburants
vous travaillez sur toute la partie de
tiges vertes et non pas sur le grain
donc vous préserver non seulement vous
préservez la partie alimentaire mais on
va même beaucoup plus loin
vous produisez vous produisez des
produits de substitution des céréales
par le cracking qui permettent de lutter
contre les importations de soja
christian jacob il ya hier entre 150 et
200 agriculteurs qui manifestaient
devant la préfecture de laval en mayenne
contre l'arrêté qui réglemente depuis
janvier les distances minimales de cinq
à dix mètres entre les habitations et
des zones d'épandage est ce que vous
comprenez leur colère ou vous leur dites
que non c'est bien de bloquer à 10
mètres les zones d'épandage je trouve
que ça n'a aucun sens soit un produit
autorisé soit il est soit il est
interdit parce que pourquoi 5 m et
pourquoi pas dit m et pourquoi pas
trente mètres et pourquoi pas 100 m tout
ça na na na aucun n'a aucun sens surtout
qu'on est là dans un domaine où les
agriculteurs ont fait des efforts
énormes c'est à dire qu'on a diminué on
a diminué les doses
on travaille de plus en plus chantonnant
en tenant compte à la fois delà de la
température de l'humidité des sols du
stade des plantules et donc les doses de
produits de pesticides sont largement
diminuée et soit un produit est
dangereux et doit être interdit soit il
autorisait une dernière question avant
qu'on passe parce que nous avons aussi
des questions sur les municipales une
dernière question sur l'écologie mathieu
vous demande quelle serait la mesure
écologique la plus radicale à laquelle
vous seriez prêt vous à penser ou que
vous souhaiteriez mettre en oeuvre la
taxe carbone aux frontières européennes
il me laisse assiette plus radicales
pour vous oui immédiatement
oui basculement il faut que les 27 soit
d'accord voilà oui non mais vous me
demandez une mesure radicale grady cas
c'est ce que notre auditeur faisable oui
mais faisable immédiatement autant
faisant qu'une autre attendez elle est
autant faisable une autre il suffit
qu'une décision de conseil européen qui
qu'ils soient prises demain matin peut
être as peut être en application après
c'est une question de volonté politique
eric vous demande quelle est la position
de votre party les républicains sur les
alliances possibles avec la république
en marche pour les municipales j'ai
toujours dit que j'étais opposé à tout
accord politique parce que je ne crois
pas à ces accords de coin de tam auront
gagné une municipale sur un projet qui
répond aux attentes de ceux de ses
concitoyens dans sa ville ensuite après
il peut y avoir des points de
convergence un certain moment et
d'ailleurs on l'a vu le localement il ya
pu avoir des accords qui sont passés et
moi en tant que président de parti
je me suis toujours opposée à ces
accords de partie je crois que la
réponse que l'on doit à nos compatriotes
elle ne se fait pas sur ces accord de
boutiquier aux européennes
emmanuel macron à siphonner
littéralement votre électorat de droite
quasiment un électeur de françois fillon
sur deux a voté la république en marche
est pas l air vous espérez quoi aux
municipales christian jacob comment la
moitié d'entre eux rentrent à la maison
d'abord parce que l'élection n'est pas
n'est pas de même n'est pas de même
nature
ensuite la force d'une famille politique
comme la nôtre c'est notre notre ancrage
sur les sur les territoires moi je suis
assez confiant sur les municipales
d'abord parce qu'on a des maires qui ont
fait leur travail
et qui aujourd'hui sont plutôt reconnus
par leurs populations et ensuite parce
que la marque de fabrique des
républicains c'est justement là la bonne
gestion la bonne gestion locale et et on
a besoin effectivement après les
défaites successives de pouvoir de
pouvoir rebondir d'ailleurs quand on
reprend les les résultats enfin les
objectifs qui étaient ceux de la
république en marche vous souvenez vous
de monsieur castaner qui nous disait
partout dans toutes les villes il y aura
des listes la république en marche on
voit combien il a réduit les objectifs
aujourd'hui nous parle je crois de dix
mille conseillers municipaux c'est ça
son objet qu'un objectif d'ailleurs
raisonnable je pense qu'ils obtiendront
ça représente 2 % des conseillers
municipaux d'eau pour une fois monsieur
castaner et lucide
bon je pense qu'il atteindra
effectivement les 2% de me conseiller
municipal et ça vous semble faisable
ça nous semblait gagnable paris parce
que aujourd'hui
l'alternance à anne hidalgo il ya une
personne qui l'incarnent à paris c'est
rachida dati soit on est favorable à la
politique menée par anne hidalgo et à ce
moment là les parisiens botteron indigne
d'algos les listes and is hidalgo soit
ils n'y sont pas favorables et la seule
qui est capable d'incarner l'alternance
c'est rachida dati qui fait oui mais pas
très loin derrière
c'est à dire si on regarde c'est lille
aujourd'hui les sondages et son foie à
ce stade oui on les prend en compte
après je vous dis pas qui correspondront
résultat mais la réalité aujourd'hui
c'est que rachida dati à la fois par son
énergie son tempérament mais aussi par
le le projet qui touche les parisiens au
coeur sur la sécurité sur la propreté
sur le logement sur la mobilité
on voit bien qu'elle est passé en quatre
mois de 11 12% à plus de 20%
donc soit on est favorable à hidalgo
soit on veut changer et si on veut
changer ses dates y allait d'un question
la cour d'appel de paris a ordonné hier
la libération de patrick balkany pour
raisons de santé vous saluer oui et j'ai
une pensée amicale pour patrick balkany
je pense qu'il était heureux de passer
la nuit la nuit chez lui parce que je
sais que le moment était difficile a eu
des gros soucis de santé
je suis très heureux pour lui qu'il ait
plus dormir enfin chez lui combien
président jacob merci je rappelle que
vous présidez donc le party les
républicains je vous offre pour la route
le tweet de cécile duflot sur vos propos
on ne peut pas opposer écologie et
productivisme elle vous cite je n'arrive
pas à traduire les smileys seront plus
compliquées mais mais mais l'écologie
est né dit elle de la prise de
conscience des dégâts du productivisme
et de ses conséquences sur le climat et
la biodiversité
et elle souligne cette époque où les
mots n'ont plus aucun sens voilà je vous
le donne non ah bah vous voulez pas
voilà je voulais lui en tout cas qataris
mais pas chez les républicains
merci infiniment 10 ans écolo voilà les
surfer sur les rails et rien mais rien
ne l'arrêtera
8h47